welcome back to new rockstar spiderman
no way home looks more and more like the
wildest crossover event
in the history of marvel studios sony
collaborations but how the hell does it
make any sense with whatever
sony shenanigans they're pulling with
craven hunter and venom and carnage like
should we all just take a cue from kevin
feige and just like
nod along to everything amy pascal's
saying is that we're all in on this
secret plan
this is rogue theory the show where we
pitch the wildest theories for the
movies that we love i'm eric voss
and helping me figure out sony's secret
plan today
is a panel including mt hey what's going
on guys let's go rogue
let's go let's do it also jessica
clemons
let's go art and our buddy tommy
bechtold
hello everyone i look forward to going
rogue with you today
tommy is everything okay does philip
have a have a
have a resistance band ready to just
it's just a new me it's a new tommy i am
no longer out of control
i'm not gonna say unhinged things
anymore and uh
you can expect just some very vanilla
calm takes from me from now on wow i
hate this time yeah
we'll fix that by the end of this we'll
we'll get you
we'll keep you from going this reminds
me of that spongebob where he's like
normal and smooth
smooth
well uh let's talk about this guy
spider-man no way home and whatever
sony's plan
is because sony executive sanford penich
said in an interview this week that they
actually do have a plan to link aaron
taylor johnson's craving the hunter
and venom and carnage and morbius living
vampire
to the mcu-based world of tom holland
spider-man
and this executive said quote there
actually is a plan
i think now maybe it's getting a little
more clear for people where we're headed
and i think when no way home comes out
even more will be revealed so okay
what is this mystery plan uh and what do
you think this tells us about spiderman
no way home when it comes out this
december i
feel like they're just saying that we
have a plan just because they know it's
going to be the multiverse and they're
like yeah a lot has come out and it's
like
well yeah we know we're going to get
into the multiverse but i think they're
playing with these characters if they're
supposed to all come together i feel
like the only way they can come together
is if in uh let there be carnage carnage
like
finds a um finds a new person to attach
to that's not cletus
and then in the next film he gets
together with craven to
destroy uh venom and i think the way
they'll get craven involved is by being
like this is the ultimate hunt don't you
want to do this and it'll be like
yeah this is a crazy ass guy i would
like to kill him
and that's when they bring in morbius to
be on like venom's side but he's not
really on anyone's side i think venom's
just using him to be like how can i beat
these two monsters
when i'm just one symbiote and he'll be
like well here's a few
concoctions i can give you but that is
truly like the only way i think they can
have all four of these people meet up
and it's also still sony not really mcu
so it's like
you guys still have these properties you
can still work with them without having
to like get too into the mcu stuff right
now so you're thinking uh kind of
symbiote war
or some kind of symbiotic infection that
jumps from person to person
and then that kind of bridges them i
don't yeah because i don't think carnage
is gonna die and let there be carnage so
it's like
what other way can they all be grouped
together like truly what other way can
they i mean multiverse is still the
answer
all of us seem to still be going to when
it comes to no way home
and how alfred molina and jamie foxx are
coming into that story but
that is not an answer yet it's more of a
question
like okay so what's the multiverse gonna
look like and why is it coming in just
because doctor street that doesn't
answer the question of why we need peter
parker who's just been
unmasked at the end apart from home that
doesn't seem like oh multiverse is the
next step from that it seems like
fugitive peter is the next step from
that
so i'm still kind of curious they must
have some kind of narrative plan for why
the multiverse has to be
in this next three qual for tom holland
well
uh erika if you don't mind i uh i'll
interject here because if you
those of you that watch rogue theory
religiously as i do
will recall a theory i had uh six to
seven months ago
where i explained why uh at least eddie
brock
and venom are going to come into peter
parker's orbit
uh and that is because i believe that
eddie brock is going to be the
muckraking journalist
that exonerates peter parker for the
murder
of uh mysterio i believe the
journalistic
instinct in a kind of a reverse from the
comics where they're adversaries
i believe that this one is going to have
eddie brock become friend
to peter parker i mean we've already
established now that venom is
good in this universe right like venom
is a at least he's chaotic neutral like
he's not uh
maybe his instincts are to do bad but as
long as he's bonded with eddie brock
he's going to be uh on the side of good
so i think that we will see
craven and carnage possibly team up as
jessica said
but spider-man's gonna need some help
too and in that case he's already got a
friend in eddie brock
maybe in one of the final scenes of uh
maybe
maybe maybe in the final scenes of uh uh
final scenes of spider-man 3 we're going
to get a
eddie brock possibly saying like hey kid
if you ever need me
just reach out and where does he gonna
where is he gonna need him when he's
literally being hunted by two of the
most dangerous people on earth now where
does more
mobius the living vampire come from i
don't know i don't i don't know
jared leto's handsome maybe he's doing
some modeling maybe he's just doing a
modeling job
nearby maybe he's just on a poster yes
as morbius
as he's just doing he's doing a 30
seconds tomorrow's video or something
i'm not sure i don't really have that
but uh
i i do believe that i believe the
connection to all this starts with eddie
and peter yeah tommy i think that's a
really good answer for
why eddie brock needs to meet tom hall
and peter parker those narrative
implications seem directly dovetailed
for me
uh and i guess the implication of that
answer would be all these other
characters in the sony spin-off
movies um they just haven't met peter
parker yet but that he does kind of
exist in their world they just
haven't been in new york or they haven't
you know gone to that part of queens in
particular just haven't crossed paths
yet
do we think i want to ask you guys do
you think it's possible that in their
universes
that the peter parker of that universe
might be dead in each of those spin-offs
yes i very much think he's probably dead
at least the main reason why we don't
see peter parker in the venom universe
is because
he probably was murdered maybe by the
the inheritors which is what i think
could be the reason um we could be this
link to at why these actors
that have played spider-man villains in
the past are coming into the mcu because
um if you remember from the original
spider-verse story
the inheritors used spider-man villains
as hunting dogs or at least verna did
the inheritor to hunt down spider
totems across the spider verse so maybe
we can see a variation of this where um
you know
these inheritors are using these various
spider-man villains from across the
universe
to hunt down spider-man while he's on
the run from the government as well so
he's just like i am being chased by
all of these weird forces that are after
me i mean he doesn't quite understand um
the full scope at the beginning but
yeah i think that that'd be a really fun
way to uh you know sort of tease that
like the multiverse exists
and though like those versions of you
know of spider-man villains that would
be
hunting spider-man you could reuse
those actors in you know a different
universe movie because the multiverse
existed so like just because
they were to appear as an inheritor um
hunting dog for lack of a better term um
in you know spider-man 3 it doesn't mean
we can't have a different
you know um craven universe craven
with his own solo movie that is
completely separate from that character
that is introduced i think that
you know with the spider-verse there's a
lot of opportunity for recasting in that
way
which is really interesting but anyway
empty i think that gives a really good
answer
for you know why the spider-verse is
necessary in this story
like i i'm kind of feeling like maybe
peter parker in this universe he's on
the run and that the inheritors are
targeting universes where
that particular peter parker is
specifically vulnerable
compared to other universes where he's
like on top of his game he's still kept
the secret you know
he's not a fugitive uh he didn't
boneheadly hand
off tony stark's glasses just based off
some [ __ ] stories
but yeah i that's what i kind of want
because
i think we all on some level want a
multiverse story a spider live-action
spider-verse but into the spider-verse
did such a good job
having this kind of simple i guess you
could say simple
story of kingpin trying to resurrect his
uh his wife and his kid
and then using a hadron collider to
split
into different dimensions to try to
snatch them from those dimensions and
have a collision there
but like what are you going to do in the
live action version another version of
that where some lab experiment causes
the realities to glide
are you going to rely on wanda vision
events
and multiverse of madness events we
don't know if sony's going it's got to
look at the playbook as much of what
kevin feige is cooking up in his other
titles so i'm not really sure how much
it's going to overlap with what the rest
of the mcu is doing
um so i like mt's idea of it just this
external force this external conflict of
like
the the multiverse is something that's
just already in perpetuity outside of
our reality
and that our reality now in the mcu is
just being targeted
by these events specifically because
peter's on the run
but what's also notable is that like you
know these these inheritor
people exist outside of the mcu and with
loki we're getting introduced to the
first beings
that exist outside of the mcu one of the
many beings that exist outside of like
the main core universe and that's the
tva
so like the inheritors are sort of like
the tv in in that sense that they
exist outside of um of the entire
multiverse
so um you know with with loki where
there is some some type of precedent
being sent for
for beings like that what's stopping
this from just being sony's
own coming um i guess in that regards i
guess it doesn't have to connect to loki
because they're doing their own thing it
seems like sony likes to take those
characters that we don't really know
much about
or that people aren't that excited about
and try to inflate them to be bigger
things so
either if it's for money or if it's for
just like merchandising
they choose these characters
specifically maybe because marvel
wouldn't real or the mcu wouldn't really
take them
so what's stopping sony from just
creating these four properties
just so they can start doing their miles
morality nothing's stopping them at all
other than i think a current fan
attachment to tom holland
in fact they are contracted to pay him
yeah exactly
home and uh a future marvel team-up
movie beyond that i think is what his
contract
is but you're right jessica i think what
sony has done in the past is just kind
of identify
whatever they can get from the mcu and
pair them up with their tom holland
peter parker
and try to get the most out of it
whether that's you know uh
tony stark whether that's the scrolls
the nick fury
um and the events of the end game like
the aftermath of end game and now it's
uh doctor strange um and i think that's
kind of the big question at the back of
our minds is like why else would you
bring doctor strange in this movie
if not to explore the multiverse just to
see him perform the winds of wood too
in the cruise advance is that what we're
most excited to see it's just for a
magic show it's peter's
birthday it's like good enough for me
i i just like i just want to see what
cool haircut he has that's all i care
about also side note it was tom
holland's birthday yesterday oh my god
happy birthday tom holland yeah we know
it's tom holland's birthday this week
because we were all hoping there would
be a no way home trailer on that day
but no smh let us down sony and
tom holland just kidding knockout
humbling but let us down
nope you did tom holland i'm talking to
you you're 25
was there an age limit for talking [ __ ]
it's like you know what i'm not i'm only
because you're 24
you just wait as soon as you can rent a
car you can talk [ __ ]
that's that's a good rule that's a good
rule i get trolled every once in a while
by the kid who played billy in one
division
and he's a kid and he's a good actor and
he seems like a really nice kid you
can't talk
i get it i always take it because you
know i honestly deserve it
but uh two it's like i'm not gonna yell
back at a kid
i would actually pay to see you getting
a twitter fight with that
a twitter war between anywho
well i think we covered some interesting
theories for what sony's plan may be and
we can conclude at least that sony's
plan is to not
correctly deliver on fan expectations of
when their
marketing materials might come out no
but someday
they will so i think the rogues of those
theories was probably
mt right for bringing in those mariners
so rogue that i honestly think that
might be the plot of end of the
spider-verse too that's like an animated
film
because it kind of seems like yes
perfect for that but
i just want to see the inheritor so
badly because like that's one of the
first stories i read when i first got
into comics so
yeah it's a coin um now we're gonna talk
some more about uh
marvel's future on disney plus in the
series moonlight
but first a quick shout out to our merch
partners epic hero
merch which uh you can find all of our
great merch options at
newarksourcemerch.com
we have a special limited edition loki
inspired design dropping very soon
uh you can find all of our great merch
options including the shirt i'm wearing
at new yorksourcemerch.com okay and we
wouldn't think some people helped us
make this episode
our friends at upstart thank you for
sponsoring this episode paying off debt
can feel like an uphill battle
high interest rates can keep you in an
endless cycle of debt well upstart can
help
get you out of that cycle and get ahead
upstart is the fast and easy way
to pay off your debt with a personal
loan all online
whether it's paying off credit cards
consolidated and high interest standard
funding personal expenses over half a
million people have used upstart to get
a simple fixed monthly payment
upstart looks at your income and
employment history instead of just your
credit score this means they can offer
smarter rates with trusted partners
with a five-minute online rate check you
can see your rate up front for loans
between one
thousand to fifty thousand dollars
receive funds as fast as one business
day after accepting your loan find out
how upstart can lower your monthly
payments today when you go to
upstart.com
rogue theory that's upstart.com road
theory don't forget to use our url to
let them know we sent you loan amounts
will be determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application go to
upstart.com
road theory we also want to thank
expressvpn for sponsoring this video
so coming out of the last year of being
stuck indoors with our family or
roommates i think we're all valuing
privacy
more than ever you know who doesn't
value privacy that much
internet service providers don't value
privacy that much
they know every single website you visit
they're judging you they're all
snickering about it and then they they
write uh mean things about you and their
little slam books
and then they sell that information to
ad companies and tech giants who
also all get on that little laugh train
and make fun of you
and write little uh entries in the slam
books and sell that to other third
parties
and then that information is just out
there in the world and in forever and
ever being sold to rogue parties and
your life is ruined right this just
turned into the plot of mean girls
life is mean girls don't you forget it
well expressvpn prevents all that by
creating a secure encrypted tunnel
between
your device and the internet so your
online activity cannot be seen by anyone
it's super easy to use just fire up the
app click one button
and it's rated number one by cnet wired
and the verge it works on phones
laptop even routers so everyone who
shares your wi-fi can be protected
it's one of the fastest vpns out there
you're gonna love it at new rockstars we
use expressvpn on all our devices
and its speed and its ease of use have
been a total game changer for us so
secure your
online activity by visiting
expressvpn.com
roguetoday that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
rogue and you can get an extra three
months for free expressvpn.comrogue
and we want to thank our friends at
bluetooth for sponsoring this video so
our friends at blue chu have a unique
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
but in chewable form and at a fraction
of the cost
blue chew is an online prescription
service so no doctor's office or
pharmacy trips and ships right
to your door in a discrete package you
sign up at bluechew.com consult with one
of their licensed medical providers and
once you're approved
you receive your prescription within
days their licensed medical providers
work with you to find the right
ingredient in strength and if you hate
swallowing pills
good news blue chew is chewable just
like it says
in the name so if you could benefit from
some extra confidence when it's time to
perform
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information and we've
got a special deal for our audience
try bluetooth free when you use our
promo code get checked out just pay the
five dollars in shipping
that's bluetooth.com promo go to rogue
to receive your first month free and we
thank bluetooth for sponsoring this
episode let's get very serious and talk
about oscar isaac playing moon knight
so oscar posted a selfie with a
collection of moon knight art and
everyone's like whoa it's confirmed that
oscar isaac's playing moon night
for the fourth time this was confirmed
but
people need to write headlines they get
it um but it has left us wondering
what's going on with the show
you know ethan hawk is gonna be playing
some mystery villain on the series and
we don't
know really anything about it um other
than what we know from comics
um so uh i want us to talk about moon
knight right now who do you think ethan
hawk what villain is he gonna play and
how do you think this series is gonna
tie into the rest of the mcu because at
the moment i'm having trouble making the
connection
as we all know moon knight is a uh it's
a mercenary who returns back to america
and
uses his money from a mercy to grow a
small fortune
becoming a bit of a a millionaire maybe
a billionaire
and who do rich people hang out with
eric other
rich people bring in ethan hawke
you're not going to waste ethan hawk on
some no-name character
you're going to give him a big banger
and this is why i think ethan hawk is
not just coming in for moon knight
i think ethan hawk is coming in for many
many many marvel movies
as we introduce him as the character
norman
osborne heard of him wow oh my god
okay he's a great age
he's the perfect age to play him he can
play him in like nine more movies if we
want
we can introduce harry osborn his son i
don't know
find a hot young actor to play him or
actress
i don't care and maybe it's harriet
osborne it's 20 21 baby there are no
rules
yeah i would love a harriet osbourne not
even going
live sorry this is a great rogue theory
i love that idea that's i mean look if
for willem dafoe to come in as norman
osborne in no way home i'd love some
version of that but i don't know if he's
like gonna be the permanent norman
osborne of the mcu
i think ethan hawk norman osborne makes
a [ __ ] ton of sense i love
i thought it would be fun and i think
because i was staying in the realm of
moon night
i think it would be fun okay so yeah we
got we got ethan hawk right
you know who steals each other's roles
ethan hawk
and kevin bacon i feel like they both
audition for the same stuff and i think
it's because they both
are these like skinnier older white men
that play the role of villain with a lot
of money
very well so i think he would be playing
yes correct a very wealthy man and i
think that wealthy man would be midnight
man
i think it would be very fun if he's
playing midnight man from
uh moon night because i think ethan hawk
would play a great character that's just
very wealthy and not trying to steal for
more money just stealing because he
wants to own everything
and then i don't think he would be the
heart of the villain for it because it's
a series
and midnight is our midnight man is not
that cool
um i think uh it would be like the fact
that he'd be the miniature part and the
bigger villain would be bushmen
because they work together some at one
point to like try to defeat moon knight
it doesn't work but i feel like that's
what they would do for the series is
like
oh here's multiple villains but one i
think ethan hawk what do you think an
idea
okay okay i do like that that's a really
good idea i think that ethan
hawk could actually be playing you know
i don't mean i don't mean to to to take
your your thing eric but
he could be playing the fist though
though
you know we are getting into the realm
of like gods and like supernatural
elements
you know thor four is going to get into
the whole god elements so like maybe the
events of thor force something happens
to like you know all these pantheons and
uh konchu
and you know mephisto are affected and
so like now enter
mooney 2 now has to deal with the
fallout of thor 4
whatever happens and like mephisto is
just like let's use this crazy guy to
buy ends i don't know
uh but i think that buffisto is you know
he's definitely coming he's got to be
coming
i would love to see mephisto in this
realm that would be very fun
and i feel like well would he he
wouldn't lose
to moonlight if we had to put those two
again
[Laughter]
i'm just like you know pandering to the
house
you are let me tell you about midnight
man for a long period of his life he
lived in the sewers as a possum man
so he was just collecting trash instead
of treasures
what's better than that's you emt what's
better than
a man that collects trash
this was an inside joke it's not me
coming at mt saying that he's a raccoon
all right but he he's the one that said
he lived at the ymca
now what would be funny is if they
introduce the marvel villain sun king
as the villain of moon knight which is
you know he's a prop he's a uh
moon knight villain and what's great and
the way that they should do this is
in the fashion of uh what do you call
the show why am i blanking on it yes
oh my god we do it in the fashion
philadelphia with dave and mommy stop it
i know
because sun avatar
in moonlight's the moon avatar so we do
day man
of the night man champion of the sun
the idea of moon night with his cape
coming through
yes and then ethan
who needs training day when you have
this
who needs any ethan hawk film when you
guys
okay never mind mg gives us my point you
know i love mephisto i'm always looking
for a way for him to get into the mcu
i had no i hadn't really thought of him
showing up in moon night
just because moon knight it seems
steeped in egyptian
mythology as opposed to christiano
judeo-christian uh mythology that
wandavision was honestly
heading towards you had your opportunity
there uh
you should have done it unless unless
they kind of do something that like the
exorcist did
and they had that demon pazuzu based in
the middle east you know
and maybe that could be some kind of
link there it's all linked to the same
mythology
oh i honestly of these three ideas i
gotta say
tommy's uh norman osborne that was very
good
absolutely absolutely i support cosine
yes thank you thank you that's the one i
most want i think
i tricked you i said i wasn't gonna go
rogue and then i went
the most rogue of all you got me
we got bamboozled the stakes have never
been higher
now comes the time for rogue questions
in which on-screen producer
zach comes up with some really funny
questions that don't always have easy
answers to come up with but there's no
way zach's watching this late in the
episode
let's test him to see if he comments on
us we'll leave our little zack attack
here no one tweet them about it let's
see if you watch it well we got two
questions first the disney plus secret
invasion series is reported to have the
working title of
jambalaya and the bizarro universe where
the series is actually an mcu cooking
show
which character do you think would make
the best chef in the mcu
honestly let's get a cooking show with
wanda and vision because we sort of saw
that in civil war with the little
with a pinch of paprika you know what i
mean when they're cooking together
so we have stone and one division two
the um the eggs julian or whatever
yeah so like those are a cooking duo
if i've ever seen one so let's get a
little uh cooking show
with one vision you know who i think
would be an excellent cook and i have no
evidence of this
jimmy wu yes i feel like i feel like
that mother he can cook it up
and he do it randomly because i feel
like at it like
yeah he's this funny character with all
these bits but then like if he was if he
was staying
up and you guys were doing something
like studying or whatever he would come
with like an
off a denver omelette toast of sourdough
bread
an english muffin and jam that can't eat
himself for sure so i think
jimmy wu i want him to cook for me for
for me
i think there's a there's uh one obvious
answer and that is
uh winter soldier bucky barnes for two
reasons
one his arm is basically a cuisinart uh
it can do
has multiple functions god knows what it
can
we know what it can be it can slice it
can dice
two he's from a bygone era where they
cook things so rich with so much
butter and so much like gravy and grease
like all of the
cooking from the 40s was made with love
to like
be eight thousand calories so the food
like the pies and savory food
yeah that's right baby they put
bucky mayonnaise doing some 1940s
delicious
cooking for us yo let's get bucky barnes
paula dean crossover maybe not paulie
never mind
oh my god you're making it worse
to make it delicious well i'm giving
jessica
the point here so we're all tied up um
and
speaking of um people saying things they
probably
regret uh so marvel studios head kevin
feige
uh just said in an interview that the
title one division
was according to him inspired by spike
lee's black klansmen because to quote
him
quote they just mushed those two words
together and the audience just accepts
that as the title i know that's the
weirdest connection ever but that's how
it came about
yikes so uh your challenge is to
uh pretend you are kevin feige's
publicist
and uh throw together the apology this
guy needs to give right now
oh oh okay i'll i'll i'll go i'll go
first
uh first first things first uh
well we want to point out some things
kevin has done right uh we want to point
out some things kevin has done right
he did not cast ellie kemper as scarlet
witch
he did not cast
he also he also he rejected the russo
brothers
original claim to call avengers end game
avengers do the right thing
he rejected that he said no to that he
said that was not okay
so kevin uh he makes some mistakes but
he also does
a lot of good things so you know you
take the good you take the bad and you
add them up and what do you have kevin
feige
i don't know if that would get him out
of the hole but i think it's a good
first start
what else we got i think i can i think i
can get him out of the hole
i know what you guys are thinking
um but you have to understand he's 47
years old
we found kevin 47 is much older in
hollywood
shut up 47 in hollywood is like uh
103. so you have to please give him a
break i mean
did you see his post when chadwick
boseman passed away it was
so great um did you see what he did for
one division
captain falcon what
you guys don't understand
how much he puts on the line and he does
it
for you marvel cinematic universe more
like marvel cinematic family
i think in both these cases we're kind
of staring more into
uh digging them a bit deeper maybe
save him empty save him i honestly if i
was
kevin feige's publicist i'd just be like
uh
whoops should have said that [ __ ]
uh remember when he made black panther
that was great let's just forget that he
said that [ __ ]
uh well kind of forever bye everybody
and at the end they go wakanda forever
am i right
i think uh a w for whoops is the best
yes the only the only thing you could
say
right now is like you should have said
that until you're getting the point
there
wow we'll see how this plays out anyway
that is our episode of rogue theory
congratulations to mt
the winner of this episode thanks
mark magnificent
well thank you everyone for joining us
uh be sure to support this channel by
subscribing if you haven't already hit
the notification bell so you get the
notifications
check out our merch options at
newarkstoresmerch.com follow all three
of our hosts on all of their social
media you can follow me at eavos
follow new rockstars and we will see you
next time bye-bye everybody
[Music]
you